e
e e
got my hammer good morning everyone um
my name is representative Terry Roy I'm
the chairman of Criminal Justice
committee over at the house I represent
um uh Rockingham District 31 with me
today uh representative Murray from
Manchester um representative Harriet
gaite from nashwa and my vice chair
representative rhods from
and
um we are here on 318 uh would you folks
like to introduce
yourselves for the
record yeah I know good morning I am
Senator Sharon Carson representing
Senate District 14 and I chair Senate
Judiciary I
represent oh I know
a lot of good work on this bill and uh
really appreciate where we are and I'm
Jeff Bradley thank you uh Mr President
um it has been a a a long slog for all
of us um and last time we met um I I
made a commitment that we would um look
at this in depth and we would spend time
doing it and I feel like we've upheld
that and we put a lot of work into this
and looking at the Chang the Senate made
you did as well um and we've all taken
this very seriously with that there's
only a few things that we wanted to
address to see that if we could come to
a um an agreement on and I'll start the
first one I believe it seems to be just
a misunderstanding of
money the 1.6 1.7 million that was going
to be split between the house uh excuse
me between the court and the uh law
enforcement with regard to the bail
track tracking system that was removed
but my understanding is that it's going
to be it was possibly going to be funded
to Opera um or some maybe you could
speak to that yeah that was my hope and
um I don't know if it's on the fiscal
committee agenda for June um I thought
that everybody was okay with that but I
guess I would recommend since it's
pretty important to the bill that we
keep it in for now okay I was going to
suggest some type of contingency
language yeah exactly exactly all right
so let's if we agree on the amount we
agree on its importance it's going to be
in there before we sign one way or the
other so so I had hoped it would be in
May but um just chairman Roy so you know
the process yeah most of the arpa money
has been allocated so there is some
monies that have been allocated but not
spent that are being returned that could
be used for worthwhile purposes and this
was a worthwhile purpose so I
highlighted it um but there wasn't
enough um room to do it in May okay so
we're going to just like I said if we
put contingency language if the money
from arer doesn't appear we'll fund it
um through the general fund we agree
excellent thank you um let me see um
there was one other issue I wanted to
mention before I give it to my colleague
um and if you just bear with me one
second it was
okay so um there was a change in the in
the standard um to hold someone um we
had clear and convincing evidence as a
standard to hold someone
um for either danger or Flight Risk um
the Senate moved it to preponderance of
the evidence um there's an arguments out
there that regarding Constitution from
the Solano case I don't particularly buy
into that having said that though I
think that holding someone um their
Liberty there should be a little bit of
a higher standard so what I was going to
propose to the Senate is how about if we
split it and say preponderance of the
evidence for someone who is a Flight
Risk and the clearing convincing
standard still if it's holding someone
for danger um and I was wondering what
you thought about
that okay does that sound
so we both get something there if
someone is um dangerous enough they need
to be held the evidence is going to be
just a little bit higher that they are
dangerous all right um with that I would
um int or not introduce but hand it over
to uh representative rhods she had a
particular issue she wanted to address
thank you excuse me thank you Mr
chairman thank you um all of our
esteemed colleagues for being here today
the the one thing that I very much would
like to address is the fact that we
clearly agree on far more than we
disagree on and um on this particular
issue I'm curious if it if it even was
intentional it could have been also an
oversight but if you look at page 33 of
our side by-side comparison uh we did
have in there for if a person had been
arrested if it was a if it was a you
know a specific crime that had like a
victim if you will and a violence crime
and we had where if the person was going
to be police that there would be um
ankle monitoring like a bracelet and
that the police would notify the victim
um give the give about an hour if you
will um for the victim to be able to if
they feel like they need to be get to
safety and I noticed that the
notification had been removed and I
wasn't sure if that was uh if that was
meant to be removed um if it was I would
like to discuss the possibility of of
having that in there I think it's very
very important um for the victims safety
for the victim's uh sense of security
and my understanding is that there will
be no fiscal responsibility at all um
and they also I do know victim Advocates
do let some somebody know if a person is
being released from incarceration you
know prior to their release they their
notified of that so I would really like
to see if we can discuss that and have
that okay be put back in there uh
representative do you want to tie that
to violent crimes only because if you
have what would be constituted as a
victimless crime you don't want the
police to have to just go notify
everybody in a particular neighborhood
that this person is out I think it would
be more appropriate if someone has been
a victim of a crime that they be
notified but we also don't want to tie
the hands of the police and it really
comes down to um what is reasonable what
is a reasonable effort and I think if we
can agree on that the police will make a
reasonable effort rather than a time
frame um and and really leave it up to
them to decide whether or not um you
know how they're going to be able to
contact the victim I think a reasonable
effort would work for the Senate so uh
thank you Senator if I may yeah uh
basically everything you said is is what
I was thinking I I wasn't looking at if
a person you know if it was involved in
like a shoplifting or anything like that
I I was looking at more of a a a
personal
a a a personal crime against a person if
it's a you know domestic violence of
course is something we hear about a lot
um if it's any kind of a a an assault it
doesn't even have to be a sexual assault
but you know even even of course an
attack I think that it would be it would
be in the victim's best interest to be
able to at least have you know a heads
up that that person is being released
you know on bail uh we had originally
put in there an hour and we thought well
if the officer or you know someone in
the police department makes a phone call
they're not able to get hold of the
person possibly drive out there leave a
note at the door that's all very very
easily documented in my opinion and when
when we talked about this I do know that
everybody that testified nobody nobody
raised any kind of concern that they
didn't think it was going to be possible
or if it was going to be you know too
encumbersome to the department I think
that um I think the reasonable effort
though is is acceptable I to your point
uh it's very difficult to micromanage
police work from from this building and
when you say you have an hour you know
what does that mean do you have to spend
the whole hour doing it I mean I think
if we put in there a reasonable effort
shall be made by the law enforcement to
notify victims prior to a an as salant
being released I think the house would
would like that does do my colleagues
all agree with that representative here
G oh good so I think we have an
agreement on that okay excellent thank
you Senator representative Murray I just
wanted to check that do we are we in an
agreement in terms of like the language
that was here for um um it being a crime
of violence against an individual person
including any Act of stalking or
criminal threatening yeah that pretty
much covers what of course because at
the end of the day if you make that
reasonable effort to notify that person
then can go to the court immediately get
an and have an experte Hearing in a
restraining order if they feel they need
to have that so um I'm I'm I'm okay with
that I think it's the right thing to do
Mr chairman would we keep the July of
2024 or the start date on that the the
effective date on that I can't see a
reason not to that unless the Senate has
an alternative I mean that's just a
matter of them start I'm just looking at
our list of dates so I that was what I
put down there okay thank the only time
that the dates come into issue is when
we start talking about money and I think
that we'll keep a close eye on that
representative Harry gather do you have
an issue that you wanted to
address might want to pull that closer
they're not picking up
right right well thank you thank you all
for being here and appreciate this time
to actually discuss this
318 um my concern was the magistrates
and um it's sort of been like a real
baby for me in terms of I think we asked
for 15 originally um and at some point
we were down to 10 another point we were
at 5 and now we're at three so
um for the work that they have to do I
would say that it's almost almost
impossible for them to get that work
done with just three magistrates
obviously they would be probably be
working quite a bit so um my request is
that at least we try to go back to at
least five and maybe um next year put
something in there for the traditional
five but even if we don't do that piece
I do believe that based on the work that
they would be doing that um the judicial
system would probably be asking for
magistrates anyway within their budget
so
and before you respond I just I and I
didn't do it I want to give
representative GA credit the the the
whole concept of magistrates has been
hers and she brought it up I think this
is what the fourth year we've we've deal
with that so um I think the concept
itself is is a is really a great concept
and I hopefully the court will be able
to take advantage of it to utilize these
quasi judicial officers in a way to to
free up the judges so that we can get
these backlogs moved along so anyway
thank you um um I can resp respond um
this is a new program and one of the
things that we had talked about doing is
tying the magistrates at this point to
the violent crime aspect so the only
time they would be involved is when
someone is being accused of a violent
crime the bail Commissioners can take
care of all the smaller issues um and I
think that's a good division of work um
we looked at the cost of having more
than three which was
expensive and we're not in a budget year
and yesterday I had a conversation with
the Chief Justice and he was fine with
the three to begin as long as they're
tied to violent crimes only but I think
it's important to realize that if they
need more they can always go to fiscal
and they can ask for more and next year
is a budget year and we will have had
the opportunity to uh to have to see the
magistrates and how they're working and
if we need to make Corrections we're in
a budget year so if the court feels they
need more they can make the request but
we just felt very comfortable because of
the cost um of the magistrates and we're
not in a budget year we arrived at three
as long as they're tied to violent
crimes
only is it the position to send that
that's the best you can do is the three
yeah that's that is the best we can do
at this point okay we'll we'll put it
pin in that for a minute um
representative Murray I'm sorry did you
have any other issues you want
representative Murray did you have an
issue that you wanted to bring
out um I mean the biggest thing on my
mind was the money for the bail tracking
system but do we agree at the beginning
that that's I think you had something
regarding homeless people or um you
wanted to the the oh um the language
that was removed in terms of sudden cash
bail for Indigent people like people who
can't um afford it that was removed and
I think that's really important to us
that we can um not roll back the parts
of uh the bail reform originally that
were to protect people from being held
simply because they can't afford bail um
and so we were wondering if that's
language that we could insert back into
the bill yeah I think that I think that
what where our goal is uh I think and we
all agree cash bail really isn't for
people who are dangerous if they're
dangerous they need to stay in jail um
cash bail is to ensure someone who might
not otherwise show back up to court and
and it should hurt them but it shouldn't
be used to trap them so I feel like if
maybe we use the language of the court
that the court already has the standard
of incy um that might be something we
could use to say if they meet that
standard then they can't have cash bail
higher than they can afford right and
that was the original purpose of bail
reform is that we did not want to be
holding
individuals just because they were poor
yeah and so we can work around some
language to get that in place we have no
problem with doing that it's just making
sure we get the right language okay I if
I could jump in sure absolutely I'm in
agreement with that as long as you know
the parameters of what we're trying to
do with the crimes that are articulated
in this doesn't automatically give
somebody a pass just because they're in
oh no I don't think it should touch at
all on the fact we have that list of
crimes that that that this just this
would only be for people who are
eligible for cash bail that list would
not be eligible just based on the nature
of that crime so I think we're covered
on that and I would agree with you 100%
this is where they say okay we would
like to make sure this fellow terms or
this um woman comes back for her Court
dat we're going to set cash bail we all
know that if you set F cash bail at $500
on a homeless person you might as well
have just said he's not getting bail so
we just want to avoid that situation so
if we use the court standard for urgency
like we agreed to I think we'll be fine
um and I think that was that was it for
the house um so if you would mind um
could we take a 10-minute recess and
discuss the one thing that we still have
to come to agreement on the number of
magistrates um and then reconvene 10
minutes
sure um
Mr chairman it to to answer U Mr
President's it starts on on the side by
side on page 16 and paragraph
2 there's also minut
for
e
e e
okay we're back on the record um we've
had a chance to talk um have um you know
we we would still like to see if you
could do five if the money's there okay
je well we talked about that so I think
a rational way to proceed is to allow um
a request to be made of the fiscal
committee for up to five we're
authorizing three this is something that
fiscal um routinely does yeah and I
think that would if there's a need for
five that will clearly be able to come
before fiscal yeah um you know for next
June when there's a new budget okay so
we're guaranteed the three and if fiscal
approves the next two yes we'll get the
five and then from then on it's up to
the court in the budget is that correct
great I think that was our final thing
we would just want to make sure the
language is correct on the indigency um
the language we put in the original bill
um what was it again
Alie the court shall have the authority
under paragraph one to set a cash bail
amount only if it is an amount which the
defendant is able to meet um remember
what page that was 10 10 thank
you now I I'm not married to the exact
language but I am married to the exact
meaning so the spirit of it yeah it's
got to make sure that it does not um
that bail is not being set to hold
people okay that can't possibly meet
that bail okay yeah if we want to make
like a note that uh it applies with the
indigency like definition according to
the courts or something that would be
fine I think so I propose go ahead Mr
chairman um real quick if you you could
take a look at this the effective date
uh one of the effective dates for
January
2025 I'm just wondering if that was an
oversight if it should be I'm going to
have you just look at it because it's
the list of everything we just talked
about and I'm not really sure why we
would have it not start until the
beginning of next year not with
everything
else who set those dates did we or did
a little bit of I don't know probably
both I think I think both but I think
honestly I think some of it was in
oversight I don't think that it was
meant to not I don't think that they
were meant to not you know communicate
with each other I just think it might be
the way that it ended up happening so if
we're going to do the amendment I would
think that now would be the time I I
think um I had asked our researcher I
think you guys should also have a a copy
of that of the the effect of start dates
yeah yeah that so I'm looking at if you
look at the second page on the bottom
I'm just curious if those should
start July when everything else is
starting oh yeah the judicial training
requirements is that what you're
speaking about yeah so I I gave my copy
to the chairman
but so okay so it has effect of January
1st
2025 and but we had as an example you
know the the the hour notific or the the
notification of a person being releas
person being released I think that's
taking effect July 2024 so would we not
want these
other these other like bail Provisions
Would we not want that also to take
effect the end of July or do we want
that to not take effect until a year
from now I would think as long as I
would think as long as there's no money
or staffing issues it can take effect in
July of this year if it's got a money
Staffing or training issue the court
it's
like we well absolutely please approach
if you have something to
add hello sorry for the folks watching
at home Aron crean judicial branch
general counsel there's just a period of
time to change our forms to train our
judges to to we're not able to do it
that that that would be a few weeks to
get that all done so we we typically do
all of that for January 1 every year so
it's often the case that when bills
affecting the court take effect their
January so we can do all the form
redesign all the high Hing all the
judicial training all at the same time
okay that makes sense all right so what
if we do this the notification piece
that's something that could save lives
that could take effect this this July
that just means the police start
notifying people if someone's getting
bailed anything asked to do with the
court or training January 2025 does that
make sense that would make me feel much
better Mr chairman can you make a note
of that so that we because what I'm
going to propose it it seems like we
have an agreement yes why don't we uh
recess till tomorrow at 1:00 until we
have an actual document the final final
document M because we know what happens
sometimes um and then we will make our
official agreement and uh sign off if
that makes sense yep does everyone have
time at one o'clock tomorrow no I don't
but all righty I will be here we'll make
it happen yeah okay all right and
everyone here can make it all right so
I'm done I'm going to recess to one
tomorrow and we have an agreement in uh
principal thank you very much thank you
thank you very much we'll
pictur um I just want to Echo Senator
Bradley's comments and congratulate the
house criminal justice committee for all
the hard work that you did on this um it
was a heavy lift and you folks put a lot
of work into it and you produced a good
piece of legislation so I just want to
congratulate you all thank you very much
and I appreciate the Senate's patience
because it took us five years but we're
here y we're here we got it right that's
all that matters thank you thank you
minut
e
e e
okay everyone we're ready to go if you
are um this is the committee of
conference for House Bill
1292 my name is represent Terry Roy from
Deerfield Rockingham 31 chairman of the
criminal justice committee I have um
with me my VI Vice chairman um Jennifer
rhods from cheshier um we have um
representative Dennis Manion um where
you from Dennis Salem Rockingham 5 and
we have uh representative muse from
Portsmouth and we are here to discuss
the differences between
1292 um with that the only really the
change is the one made by the Senate and
I'd rather just have you guys tell us
what what what your thoughts
are so thank you um thank you very much
Mr chair and we
added
um Senate Bill 563 which is our
Sanctuary City bill which you folks
tabled I think 177 to 18 188 and we're
hoping for a second shot at um in
passage of sanctuary cities I I'm happy
to talk about why I think they're
important but I suspect that everybody
has already heard me a thousand times on
that and they know the arguments
backwards and forwards it's up to you
I'm happy to go into it further but I'll
leave that to your
discretion Well yeah if you could just a
little background um a short background
of what what now why now I think we all
agree that there's an issue but why now
would be helpful I think so um
I think we need look no further than the
difference between our state and our
neighbor to the South which has um
Sanctuary policies in place
Massachusetts is spending almost a
billion dollars annually to house and
take care of migrants and our view in
the Senate is that when you have an
incentive to come to a State visa
Sanctuary policies you will have more
people coming to the state State because
it becomes an incentive a magnet and um
I think we are concerned about that
we're concerned about um you know the
ongoing drug prices human trafficking
the potential of you know people coming
in on the terror watch list I mean these
are all issues somewhat beyond our
control obviously um but you know myself
and Senator Carson were on the northern
border um several weeks ago we met with
um Federal and local officials and state
officials there that you know describe
that situation so to me we have to do
the things that we can do so what have
we done we authorize 1.4 million in the
budget last year to assist local law
enforcement um we were told when we were
in the northern border that's helping um
the for anybody who hasn't been up there
it's very remot and it quite frankly is
very accessible from Canada you walk
across a stream that's about as wide as
this table and maybe that deep um and
it's all woods and there's a beautiful
dirt road and um you know so
people can easily cross the border if
that's their intention but because it is
so remote in the town of Pittsburgh it's
at the end of a s mile dirt road by by
the time if a local residence and
there's some there are some people on
the that road big tracks of land farms
da Farms um if they see somebody
Crossing by the time folks would be able
to come and do anything about it law
enforcement it could be 45 minutes away
so um while that's sort of a subset of
the issue we're dealing with I think the
sanctuary City bill is something that we
can do to say
um we're not going to create that kind
of incentive and I and again I think we
need to look no further than what's
happened in Massachusetts the billion
dollars people having
to um requisition community centers
Logan Airport I mean things like that
for um housing of um folks that have
crossed illegally so that's why um we're
back at it again um it is a very
important bill to the Senate are you
aware that the version that almost
passed the house had been amended I had
um when it came to criminal justice I
had amended it um because there was
language in there that suggested um I
believe it was the police shall take all
possible efforts um that was felt to be
pretty Broad and they were very
concerned so I took that out and we got
close with the amended language
so what I would say is that um just
speaking for myself and not for any of
the other Senate conferees um that would
be a rational compromise and if that's
what this Committee of conference came
to when you had a chance to sell it to
your good folks in the house I would do
everything I could to sell it to our
Senators all right well let's hear from
the other uh conferees representative
rhs thank you Mr chairman I at this time
I i y I don't have anything to say just
yet okay representative Manion nothing
representative M I assume you have
something to
say
when when this bill came before our
committee uh I had a number of concerns
and one of the biggest concerns is we
got a letter uh from the heads of law
enforcement uh from several of our
communities including our largest
community in the state
Manchester basically urging us to kill
this bill um and we have also heard uh
from uh immigrant Rights group from the
ACLU from uh from other folks in the
house who are concerned with Liberty
issues and around the due process
problems that come with the tainers and
things like that and the bottom line is
that um the state should not be in the a
business of enforcing a civil
immigration detainer when that's the
only thing that uh that an an immigrant
uh can be charged with one of one of the
issues that I had with representative
Roy's uh representative Roy's amendment
is it would actually open the door uh to
anyone being charged who's subject to an
investigation so it wouldn't even take
arrest or jailing or something like that
so one of the things we just did that
was a really good thing together is we
passed a racial profiling bill um if
you're not extremely careful about how
you implement this what you've done is
you've made that situation
worse would would you think about this
if we took the amended language and we
made it strictly if you had been if if a
person's arrested for a violation of New
Hampshire law not questioned or stopped
or anything like that only if they've
already been arrested and then and only
then it becomes to their attention that
there it may be an immigration issue
that then they should cooperate with the
immigration enforcement would that make
a difference to you so so my
understanding is what that would do is
just formalize the current policy that's
actually in place in in many departments
now yeah so when somebody's actually
arrested for a crime and New Hampshire
when they're jailed for a crime in New
Hampshire if they if a detainer is out
on them law enforcement will know about
it and they will contact ice so there's
nothing in the uh one of the reasons why
they call the they differentiate between
Sanctuary policies and and Sanctuary
cities per se is none of the the cities
that have actually passed the sanctuary
policies in New Hampshire are doing
anything that would get in the way of
that because if they got in the way of
that that would be a violation of
federal law I believe um and I I trust
me I don't want to be argumentative but
one of the members of our committee I
forgot where is she from um Kean the
policy in Kean and you can look it up on
their website is not to contact or
cooperate with ice if if I'm not
mistaken so be that as it may that so it
it is happening and if if all we're
doing is formalizing it I'm not sure
that that that would be a problem um but
I'm happy to hear your thoughts well I
think part of it part of it is how you
formalize it so for example one of the
things I think people struggle with is
the ambiguity of the language without
something in New Hampshire statute so
you know one of the reasons why we
enacted the racial profiling bill is
because we wanted to make that clear to
people as a policy statement um there no
penalties but we wanted to make it clear
to people as a policy statement that
that behavior uh uh was uh essentially
was was unacceptable so I think one of
the things that could be productive
would be actually spelling out the
guidelines of how officers are supposed
to handle these
situations um uh on the other on the
other hand and and I think one of the
things that I had given you at one point
uh was an idea for an amendment that um
uh that actually would have
would have allowed communities to issue
policies against
Sanctuary so yeah that's fine but it
also would have still left the dment for
communities to have Sanctuary so it it
kind and I mean the part of it that's
part of my objection here too is this is
you know essentially what we have in in
New Hampshire we have three communities
where we have elected officials who have
made a decision um uh to uh you know to
to support this and and it's
actually there's nothing in federal law
that actually requires um local police
to actually assist in the in the uh
enforcement of a detainer right that's
just something that we do um you know
that uh different departments have
different policies on now and I think
that's one of the issues is you have
Manchester PD has a policy you have the
state police have a policy and and one
of the things we learned about those
policies too is a lot of those policies
were actually put in effect to improve
relations with immigrant communities
which is really important in cities with
larger immigrant populations like
Manchester uh and Nashua and so part of
the police objection to this was it
would actually undo a lot of the good
that um that's been done by these
policies
um yes Senator thank you m thank you Mr
chairman u i I speak in support of the
iteration that you have just given I'm
from Manchester lived in Manchester for
the last 60
years the west side of Manchester there
has been a maximum effort by the City by
lower enforcement to bring the community
together and to integrate all of these
refugees who have come to our City and
we've been a placement center for
refugees from all from all over the
world we we've got the nepes we've got
the bosnians we've got the pakistanis we
we have a a large group of immigrants
and the relationship has been cultivated
over a period of time and our law
enforcement people are dead set against
this piece of legislation our our our
our chief of police sent a letter to
most members of the letter so
I spoke against this bill on the floor
of the Senate uh I have great respect
for my colleagues and their opinion but
my opinion is this will not work it does
not work it should not be put in place
it doesn't have any bearing at this
point in time where the money was
spending I was member of the finance
committee we allocated the money for the
northern border that was to trade
people to work the northern
border right we did that we've made that
we made that commitment I think what
people are doing other states is their
responsibility they're being run by the
politically elected officials in those
States if they deem it a responsibility
to take care of people then they they do
it they're not asking us for help so my
position should be very very clear I
will support the people in in the city
of Manchester immigrants from the city
of Manchester came up and testified on
this piece of legislation if you read
the testimony of the bill I think you
could gather you could gather all of
that I I think it it's very important
that we maintain
relationships with the people who have
come to our
community that have decided to take up
residents in our community to build
lives in our community to build
businesses in our community these people
should not be uh singled out and gone
after I I I I think it's bad bad public
policy I I I would agree that um that
would be horrible policy thankfully
that's not what this bill does
representative uh Senator Bradley uh
thank you very much so I
I New Hampshire and many other states
have the plethora of examples of people
in this country illegally that have
committed heinous crimes a mass murderer
was apprehended in New Hampshire who had
been living here illegally
if there wasn't an ice order to detain
somebody like that or they were subject
to Sanctuary policies that person
wouldn't have been apprehended there
were just two police officers shot on
the street of New York City yesterday or
the day before by illegals um so it's
example after example after example the
poor girl in Georgia who was killed I
mean I don't think I need to go any
further it's happening in our country
and the only reason it's not happening
worse in New Hampshire is that they're
only a handful of welcoming ordinances
in towns like Lebanon and um Hanover and
Kean and that's what we're trying to
stop we're trying to stop the problems
that we see in other states that are out
of
control from coming here and with all
due respect to the the Chiefs the six
Chiefs who sign it and nobody's more in
support of the Chiefs on a lot of big
issues than I am and they know it
they're flat out wrong not only
misguided but flat out wrong what we're
talking about my colleague from
Manchester is legal immigrants that are
here and the Outreach that goes to Legal
immigrants not people that the first
thing that they do when they come to the
United States of America break their
break our laws by crossing a border
illegally and if you create a magnet you
get magnet and God help us you know a
billion dollars in Massachusetts is
something that is out of control and our
budget given you know education funding
that we're going to have to deal with
next year all in all likelihood the YDC
settlements you know what we just
authorized and it's on its way to the
governor on group two fix if if we have
to spend hundreds of millions of
dollars because we've created a magnet
because we can't pass this bill because
we don't have a political where with all
to pass a common sense Bill to say we're
not going to be an incentive shame on
us um I think that it's important that
we make the distinction because
oftentimes it's not made nobody in this
um body or your body is interested in
harassing or in any way singling out
legal immigrants to this country and
them constantly being tied together by
someone saying well immigrants rights
groups we're not talking about
immigrants we're talking about criminals
who have illegally come to the country
and really I'm not even interested in
the Hampshire police policing them as
far as I'm concerned that's a federal
problem but when our law enforcement
arrest them for violation of New
Hampshire law and they become aware of a
federal issue I do not think as a policy
we should be picking and choosing when
we cooperate with the federal government
um it it's not good um I think that our
friends on the other side would object
if we were to say you shall not
cooperate with the federal government on
some other things they happen alike I
think a blanket policy of the state
should be we cooperate with the federal
government it doesn't matter who the
president is whether we like him or not
um because it changes every four years
and I'd also like to point out the
Hampshire is a state it's not a republic
the cities and towns do not get to do
what they want um they weren't um they
didn't vote to join New Hampshire um
they were within the borders when New
Hampshire was formed so they follow the
laws of New Hampshire they don't get to
just pick and choose either so I I agree
that a policy that says as a state we
will cooperate with our federal Partners
um and that goes for everything I mean
some may say well that's hypocritical
well not of me because I just supported
uh cooperating with the federal
government on gun control so as far as
I'm turn across the board we should be
cooperating with federal law enforcement
where wherever possible um having said
that it appears to me that we're not
going to come to an agreement um at this
table at this moment um I speaking as
the chair and I know two of my members
will support um going to the amended
version that the house voted on already
and if we need to what we'll do is we'll
take a recess um we can meet again
tomorrow same time as the other
committee maybe half an hour later and
come up with that version and approve it
uh yeah if I could make a suggestion
just that your version yeah and um we'll
see where we at tomorrow and um go from
there okay so we we're going to um
recess until uh 1:30 tomorrow same place
same
station everyone
agree thank you all for your time and
your input okay all
right please I apologize for my casual
attire but I couldn't stand the sweat
anymore yeah it is warm but that's okay
we
e
e e
I remember a fishing game aspect this
moment
e
e e
L it was a gift when I made
chairman um with that I am calling to
rep of the um Committee of conference on
house pill 1197 my name for the record
is representative Terry Roy I represent
Deerfield and um Rockingham District 31
um we are here to address um some
changes from the standpoint of the two
bills there's three three things
attached to this bill the criminal
justice part with regard to the
fingerprinting for the um the Educators
and stuff we're fine with that that's
good that's not even an issue for today
as far as I'm concerned
the piece with regard to fishing game
the same the last piece that we need to
discuss I'm going to hand over to
representative hunt um and let him take
it and we'll we'll get into that
representative hunt okay so um this was
the uh inter I was we making sure I say
this
inter inter uterin uterine
insemination so um originally the the
commerce subcommittee was all set to
interim study this
bill and then uh there was at the last
moment on our day of executing there was
a little uh you know uncomfort with
where what we were doing and and the way
the bill was written it was basically
written to that to say that any any any
woman could have this procedure done
okay even though this intent the
underlying intention was uh to address
uh an expression we
learned previous
year um which is
social
infertility um which the Commerce
Committee did not go anywhere with
that um
so in in the in My ATT to uh maintain
that that the Commerce Committee was
going to have any floor fights we were
going to do everything in uh in harmony
um I said let's uh move from interim
study and let's uh have an amendment
I'll draw up an amendment that would
address the
issue and um and the amendment I drew up
the amendment uh and I actually believe
you the Senate also Drew up the
amendment because then when I looked on
the the web page page you had two 20 and
21 so uh you chose instead to go with
the one that I specifically would not go
for and made it clear to everyone that I
do not consider this procedure a medical
necessity if we're if we're saying this
is offered to all women this is this is
a a benefit that that all women have
that that for whatever reason that that
this is the where they choose to get
pregnant then then um but it's not a
medical necessity it is just simply that
with the insurance company will cover it
and it really in in the end of the day
it's not going to be a big burden to the
insurance company because um you has
still has all the same cost sharing
pieces to it and uh and the matter there
and when it comes to
um getting getting uh getting fully
fertilized for all the all the other
things involved there are a lot more
expensive elements to it and this is
actually one of the smallest expense of
all and so therefore at that point I you
know said okay that's fine and but we're
not we're not specifically targeting
this to one group of people we're saying
that all women should have this
possibility so if you just remove the
medical necessity language then I I'll
be okay with it so just if I may for for
those of us who don't know anything
about this because it's not our bill um
um the
agreement both sides agree that this
procedure should be provided for and
paid for by Insurance the the
disagreement is on a description is that
really that's that's all it is at this
point is that fair that's how it sounds
to me um I don't know picking me up so
chairman hunt um I
think as you'll remember on that session
day there was lots of things flying
around so
what you're saying is um if I'm looking
at HB 1197 as amended by the
Senate um I believe our language appears
on lines 25
through
35 well yeah 20 I see 26 yeah new
section
yep so I'm looking on page 36 on the
side by side
here okay
um and
so which language specifically would you
like to I would I believe
um is
um shall provide certific hold Insurance
up to six round inconvenience
insemination per year per year
period so you see the word six the next
line says in insemination
year so that in accordance with that
that all that language is is what I
would want
deleted standard or guidelines developed
by theic
soci so I'm C I'm sorry I'm curious to
know I don't the way I just read that
it's not saying it's medically necessary
but it it's it's medically necessary for
them to get pregnant but it's not
medically necessary for people to have
is that is that correct right okay so is
that what your language intended that it
seems to me we're just talking past each
other maybe yeah I I tend to agree
representative I think that this
language was added um with the intent of
trying to make sure everyone felt
comfortable with how this mandate was
going to come into effect but um
removing the language you're talking
about um chairman after per plan per
year per plan year to me um doesn't
affect the coverage that anyone would
get and if it um if it's sort of
muddying waters that were previously
clear personally I'm fine with removing
it okay yeah then and then the last
sentence subject to a deductible C code
insurance would be kept so it's just
okay it's just a medical
necessity and all those other people who
I have no idea who they are well I guess
they're important people so from um line
28 on page 11 uh where it starts in to
technology comma is
removed
uh right so it starts with
yeah
if right so it starts with per
year per year and subject to deductible
coped right if Senator Perkins PO is
good with it so do other Comer have
anything want to have that's good to me
good to you don't know I'm
talk
um and and again I'm fine with that do
you um do you foresee any issue with
that on the house floor or do you think
that'll be an acceptable position I
think that's
acceptable we hope so
we like you that
would caucus um Brad will you be able to
handle that that
drafting yeah no I just I mean that
language capture thank you all right
excellent thank you we appreciate it
yeah I love these um with that we are
closed thank you very much thank you
sure
e
e e